[Music]
in golden pooper news golden submitted
by warlords of Joe Mallya thieves stole
a five million dollar gold toilet from
Britain's Glen Hein palace golden toilet
nothing appears that's a [ __ ] extra
ass [ __ ] dude 18 karat gold toilet
I think magic Don Juan the pimp had a
golden toilet did he maybe I might have
a mixed up with Master P how racist of
me having a gold toilet is one of the
dopest things you could have yeah but I
guess you know that is a been done
before by British royalty I kind of like
the standard porcelain toilet it's
pretty nice yeah but [ __ ] on gold
dude you don't give a [ __ ] so hard that
you're [ __ ] on gold and you're like
oh and then you're I really put the face
of my enemies oh yeah what if like the
bottom is like this yeah you're shooting
it through their mouths oh yeah see
that's what I would pay my enemies to
just be my [ __ ] like that
oh [ __ ] you wanna you just [ __ ] in their
mouth and then you wipe in their hair
you grabbed it
you grabbed her hair and just wipe your
ass off with it I'll see it a couple
hours it's really short hair though like
what if it sticks is really sharp short
pointy I would have even grow it out oh
like your hair very less right yeah
hopefully stay friends how much how much
you paying what a boring job waiting for
Steve I hope he comes and takes a [ __ ]
there's no one to talk to
I'm so bored
dude imagine they come home from their
job too and they see their wife or
whatever actually how's your day is like
yeah socks again oh if you had to be
there bird day did you hit the button
and you're like no you have to drink the
water eagle the vortex would you like
well less sounds [ __ ] not too many
sounds I love it so this toilet is
valued at more than five million dollars
it was part of an exhibition of work by
this Italian conceptual artist named
Mauricio Katella Catalan and it was open
for only two days and that's when I got
stolen so it was at the [ __ ] horrible
yeah don't work security here how did I
not see a gold toilet can you take it -
[ __ ] you - did I wonder if it was solid
gold because that's heavy as well but if
they got ocean 11 but he did something
like a team of sneaky ass [ __ ]
and they had a hologram so you thought
the toilet was there the whole time
oh I don't know
that's billion so they're saying that
the toilet was actually attached to the
plumbing like it was a working woman
so they caused a lot of damage
significant damage and flooding what the
[ __ ] is going on in this story
nobody [ __ ] caught on that there's
[ __ ] water leaking everywhere
was it an exhibit yeah yeah so I'm
assuming that came after hours right so
there probably none of the alarms went
off and I didn't go there if it's an
exhibit why would they need to plug it
into plumbing they were saying that they
were letting people use it oh [ __ ]
that's cold [ __ ] close the door that's
when they took it I hope there were no
doors no what you just have to [ __ ]
exposed everybody yeah I paid $20 to
poop in right here just to watch me poop
I poop in it why'd you poop a lot I poop
without doors she seen you poop she
doesn't need to see you program
sorry
they're saying that thieves with at
least two vehicles broke into the place
which is the birthplace of Ocean's
eleven people with Winston Churchill oh
and they remove the toilet sometime
before 5:00 a.m. so they did say that
they arrested one 66 year old man in
connection with the theft but they have
not recovered security card that they
paid off
I feel like Europe hasn't all these like
high-level thieves like that's their
thing it's so cool stealing all day art
thieves so sir pretty crazy diamond
thieves jewels thieves
remember there was that one crew that
that would go in with motorcycles into
the mall and [ __ ] and then they would
like break into the jewelry stores yeah
with the bike and then they would jump
off and like [ __ ] do something
what do you call it those yeah like like
so sir it wasn't the Mini Coopers oh
yeah are you drunk
oh yeah movie those are times are good
criminals yeah
dude taking the butt of a gun right and
break in the glass of a jewel case is
one of the sickest things that can
figure me too they should make that they
should make like a movies experience
kind of thing just like go please go rob
a jewelry store like and then but that's
the only it's like an escape room but
you just go rob a jewelry store window
oh they have they have them on like
strings and stuff and you can like how
would you pay for that like how much did
you pay for an experience on a
helicopter flying away dude are leg up
and catch it I wanna be back to back
with it as we bought everything
when you write about to have sex and in
the it goes like to darkness and then
you don't all the lights turn up oh yeah
yours is the most emotional [ __ ] ever
whatever ey the window lines raining and
do this
oh yeah that's a high one I got my new
business plan yeah does that [ __ ]
Casey with the outside window I like on
friends where you can you know there's
no excuses nothing yeah yeah just like
oh I want to go to the museum where
people just [ __ ] help you there's
someone that believe that yeah
good place watch his channel see how
well he's doing yeah we're on season 1
my breakup season what's gonna happen
season 2 yeah it's even sadder because
winter is coming
video we're like you're just thinking
about it it's like the hologram image of
her and then you turn around she's gone
take that one like like Avengers just
has a feeling who melts away feel good
only for the holidays you should hang up
all your stockings to on Christmas and
look at them alone this is how we heal
everybody we laugh the only one laughing
we are - laughing and also we're also in
committed relationships so it's fun to
like it's fun it's like I'm at the zoo
yeah go home Joe should be playing an
instrument and then you hear someone
talk [ __ ] about him he turns around
no one that critiqued me in my
instruments Joe starts working out at
5:00 in the morning and then he realizes
no one's gonna tell him to stop named
America they called it America
is it a king's toilet or someone's no
it's a piece of good work boy I mean he
just took something that already exists
any people said the same about Andy
Warhol they changed the world that way
okay he's not that og though people
already made go toilets true what did
you use those gold toilets all the time
I mean Trump [ __ ] go played at all
kinds of [ __ ] in this [ __ ] Trump have
a gold-plated toilet
I don't know about the toilet but he had
like sinks and all kinds of [ __ ] Trump
is basically a rapper but he doesn't
exactly know so they actually offered
the toilet to Trump but he declined it
last night
last year well the toilet was was at
another oh my gosh I can't get these
words out this other museum they did
offer president Donald Trump to have
this toilet temporarily installed for
his own personal use at the White House
will you turn it down
see that's that's how you told Trump
people don't know how to told Trump they
just did that that's what that is
uh-huh yeah but it would have been
better if he except how would I talk
about do you know you just you just you
just try to do something that he's
insecure about right so he knows that
he's gold toilet guy so then when you
send him a gold toilet he's gonna say no
no no cuz he loves it yeah yeah
I would have took it I work took it to
but since he didn't accept it that's
what tells you that would get them yeah
it got him
it makes him yeah people don't know how
to told Trump you just got to go after
the thing that he knows he is yeah mmm
yeah buying wigs holding like pain I
would give him like what they do all
that already it's not it's it's already
done to death right like like the Liz
Warren thing how he went after her for
being a fake Indian thing that [ __ ] was
a [ __ ] hilarious thing right and then
she comes under actually here's my DNA
test and it prove that she's the even
worse yeah 164 throw some [ __ ] just
recently come out to where she was like
the first minority woman to be a part of
the Harvard like yeah Harvard borders
yeah well she was even claiming to be a
minority she looks white as hell it's so
funny man but that's how you so he
trolled her with that right and so and
she was like insecure about it so she
[ __ ] releases a DNA test like boom
kill shot
like that's how they got Trump here it's
like hey we're sending you a golden
toilet he's like oh no thanks boom kill
shot
he should have took it like thanks yep
wait I wasn't expecting him to take it
exactly what would the joke be better if
he took it and then like just for your
own personal I'm using like I got him I
would have took it and then took a
selfie of me taking a [ __ ] and sent it
to the person I would have got an actual
professional photographer still the top
is my suit the bottom no pant would that
be like the presidential like portrait
there is nothing there's no place where
you're more vulnerable than when you're
on the John taking the [ __ ] I always
think about that was it because the
pants are the ankles
no no it's cuz you're like you're like
trying to get something out of your body
cuz I feel like that's my most ready
position Bart I wait back today I want
you to watch him poop and then you tell
me that it's so good no way the way that
I squeezed I'm ready to come up yeah
focus yeah yeah let me know when you're
gonna go so I thought when you throw up
what does that look like he's ready to
go he's just yeah
not ready to go in the toilet you say
ready to go you you you mean fight
rights I'm ready to take off your own
blocks wait who's a movie Shh
I see how fast you [ __ ] Jesus it's
pretty slow Jesus
he needs fiber come on think about a
dump when you're in those moments you
get a little vulnerable right nope good
little if I can't see if I can't look
around the corner he waits at me all the
time that's why I have a toilet gun what
a strange man
watch him I'm telling you why are you
watching him take a [ __ ] I don't have a
choice woman strange woman I bet Ryan
takes longer bullshit's don't know
that's why you have a toilet gun toilet
oil again what is that in the extra
water in the water think you know where
he's insecure ad vulnerable dude is it a
duct tape revolver maybe can you find
out come through find out he's a most
vulnerable dude